before him it was also still wild enough  for shaq to reject this idea  and shack down to  three minutes  when he had such a lead in time you know  it feels like  again  he's losing control but  maybe he can go  94.  what kind of move will he want to make  difficult too hard to say 94  does look very natural he goes queen c3  just keeping  the position tense and that's a good  move in the sense that rajov probably  didn't  didn't expect it and  i offered a draw okay  oh quincy three and he's seen enough he  felt he was losing control  oh my god offered a draw  which means that magnus carlsen is the  winner of norway chess 2022 first of all  congratulations to magnus